all right look bootleg Kev show we got a
special guest times two in here Ray J
Bobby brackens the onew
punch knock out one punch
for new record we promo we in promo mode
Ray J Bobby you guys we were just
talking 143 is a bit of a classic and
it's I can't even believe it's been 12
years 13 years since that's song came
out yeah what is uh I mean cuz you had
come in under knockout or did that
record come out under knockout n that
was Bobby record that was your record I
just I really just he told me it was
going to be a big record and I said
listen I believe in you I believe in the
record and I'm like dang he was he was
100% right the [__] is lit and um and
then it just went from there so what is
the inspiration to come back together
all these years later I mean we had
we've had the the other song Hit It
First Hit It First yes which made a lot
of noise yes and then you know I me and
Ray did verses like a year and a half
like a year ago and then it was like why
a we been making no music you feel me so
we about to do a whole EP we about to go
to studio right after this you feel me
yeah I think Bobby is really talented
he's a creative director you know writer
producer and um and you know sometimes
when you working with people that's real
creative and in their own space and in
their own bubble like they dreams is
already like it's already stamped they
already true um and it's a lot of it's
only a few other people out there I work
with that when they say something going
to happen and they manifest it you can
feel the manifestation in it then it it
actually evolves with the hard work so I
was just like listen we need to go back
in do it again we ain't never lost um
and let's just do a whole EP a body of
work and I just trust you like he he
running the whole play you know what I'm
saying wherever I could support
financially or just like me being there
following his lead through this campaign
I'm all the way in and I'm excited uh
for people who don't know Bobby
obviously we know 143 but your pen game
is pretty ridiculous you've you were uh
you helped write loyal right yeah uh
what some of the other records that
you've L Services too to for
t uh let's see I'm the one the DJ
College Justin Bieber worked on that one
did worked on ego death for Kanye and T
great [__] record shout out to Ty
Dollar um the other one for Chris was
came to do it was off that I remember
that record that was a great record is
you know what I came to do exactly and
then um I'm sorry it's all good man it's
a it's a it's a bunch of songs you know
I've been I've been a part of been done
touched you feel me writers written by
Bobby brackens on Spotify you can look
it up you feel me but definitely ever uh
you know tried to do my thing how do you
feel feel like uh cuz I feel like since
you came out Bay are has evolved so much
in terms of the music scene um I feel
like you know when you came out kind of
like the
R&B like hip hop 100 BPM I'm thinking
your record I'm thinking John Hart I'm
thinking like all that kind of [__] was
like love rants there was like this wave
coming out of California as a whole the
bay is kind of like it's kind of in an
interesting place because it's kind of
like if you think about like the biggest
artist out of the Bay right now
independent guy Larry June you know what
I'm saying like Larry homing too Larry
doing his stuff man I'm I'm proud of
Larry man so it's like Larry ain't even
had like a big radio record or nothing
exactly it's crazy right he just got
fans and parishing all over the world so
the times just changed you know like I
feel like me and Ray are artists who've
had success um like doing like radio
runs and you know getting that kind of
marketing but you know there's just two
ways to do it or you don't you know like
Larry you don't need to radio you just
get you know that little core base that
just rocks with you but you know it just
is different way Different Strokes for
different [__] was ask you though how
how do you feel about like the current
state of the Bay Area scene and who you
who you fan of I mean I mean G still one
of my brothers I love G and then um
Larry's of course doing his thing Kalani
of course is doing her thing and then um
let's see this is no kid and Cari he did
song with like the OVO click with and
him he got this song called 4: a.m. in
Oakland he doing this stuff but it's um
P's my brother you know
P to out to P my bro shout out to PO you
know but you know it's a lot of uh
creative stuff always coming out of the
bay and um now it's just you know time
to focus on what me and Ray working on
the new record new EP on the way Ray
have you been bipped in the bay
yet I've been a lot of things in the
bay um I mean that means somebody
someone cracked your window and took
something out of your car cuz you know
that's like right now the the bipping
capital of the world is the Bay Area
yeah um I've been a lot of things in the
bay but I can truly say that I haven't
been bipped got to knock on wood there
yeah I mean God is good you know I
barely Drive anymore so I might hop out
of a
uber I might catch the public transit
there you know what I'm saying no not no
oh yeah most definitely I got my whole
whip stalling and then they stumped it
out oh man they just like stripped it
they jump like TV show you feel me like
bipped I always I do feel like it'd be a
good YouTube channel to like just roll
into like downtown San Francisco with a
rental and have like a clown hidden in
the trunk right so you park and you know
you're about to get bipped how do you
know you're going to get bit because
they know what the rentals look like so
you just you know you have couple white
people parked the car look like tourists
within like 10 minutes their car is
getting bipped and then they go to open
the trunk and a clown jumps out so so so
what you're saying to me is that there's
a very high percentage that when you
park yeah high high percentage that when
you park you somebody's going to just
break your window and and take what
though anything any and everything so
right now like so like you know John C
who's uh shout out to John step P dog sh
love him uh John will leave his windows
roll down and like yo go ahead take a
peek just don't break my window a lot of
people do that like literally I have
nothing in the car just go ahead take a
look get in look around so you it's safe
to say that and I don't I don't promote
this brand I'm just I just know the
commercial but safe like repair safe
like repair yeah you're going to need a
lot of that in the B they all the way up
probably in that they're running up if
you got a window repair service I mean
the greatest repair service of all time
they get it done same day yo they B than
think you they bipped Brian Samson la
like what last month month he was
pumping gas by the Oakland Airport and
his dumbass was on the phone probably
[__] talking about food you know what
I mean like he likes and he wasn't even
paying attention and they popped his
trunk and jacked all his luggage by the
time he turned around and looked they
were already running into a car and he
can you imagine Brian trying to pull the
pump out of the thing and then chase
people in Oakland that's some Coming to
America [__] let me tell you like this
when we me and Ray just was in Oakland I
told the uh the the I'm like yo we need
two security guards to watch the cars if
we pull up we're going to pull up right
in the front we need two security guards
to watch the cars and that's exactly
what they did so you just got to kind of
move mean you got to know what you doing
you got to move kind of presidential out
there I was out there with Cassie one
day Me and You Cassie sweet little
Cassie they bipped her car took her
laptop and everything Cassie the singer
yeah so when you when when you park when
you park you been waiting so
long all time great leaks she's got they
bipped her we they took her laptop and
everything when you park in the bay have
have a security guard stand by your [__]
if you want to be super gang tight Jesus
or this Uber [__] it I mean I didn't
know that you didn't tell me about I
told you I had the security guards at
the car you had a handled had it handled
well look for all the bippers out there
in the bay we'll be out there this
weekend and um yeah there's going to be
a bull listen and what I want to tell
all the bippers is that I I listen I
respect what y'all do and I don't
just respect my [__] Mr Fab has got like
like Mr Fab is said no one's above the
bip he's been bipped twice I think in
the last like six months he might not
have had the security guards at his at
his thing but no one's above the bip you
know well then maybe we when we park we
going to bounce out and then we going to
go take the car just take your [__] with
you take the car around the car just
can't leave anything in the car yeah no
no value you know what you could do ray
to get raycon out in the street a little
you leave some raycon product in the car
dope and let them take it and feed it to
the streets now that's what now that's
real bipping what that's pimping headon
that's bipping and pimping can we look
at the trademark on bipping I like that
let's try to see what's up with that um
so yeah come get a big one bipping
sounds good I like it I like the word I
like it I feel think bur I think burner
is working on a uh movie called bipping
that's what's up that's big burn man
shout out yeah big shout out big big big
shout out Ray you've obviously been
killing it on the just entrepreneurial
side um you sold your scoot company yes
uh yeah I sold it like um a couple years
ago uh luckily right before the pandemic
you know perfect timing right too and
and I feel bad and I feel good you know
what I'm saying at the same time but um
you should feel good I feel good but I
mean my you know the guys that that that
that bought it from me you know they
they had the big bike sharing you know
platform and they still do and they do a
lot of things um in Canada with the
Business Loop share but um you know
right at the pandemic it just kind of It
kind of took a little bit of a turn for
bike sharing um and I was always in the
retail for the bike so yeah cuz you had
the bikes in like sax F A or was it I
had them in nean markets I had them in
MCM stores I had them on all the uh
players all the football teams all the
stars I mean it was it was pretty
massive um how we marketed and uh
promoted it so it was a good run for us
in the um what you can you say what you
sold it for
is it out there if it's not out there
it's it's out there you know for me I be
like I try to stay away from like like
um you trying to watch your pockets
that's all yeah right I like I mean [__]
you know for me um I just always been
low-key um but it's online but even all
kind of like all my successes in
business is kind of tucked away you know
what I'm saying I I like put in a lot of
work but a lot of people don't really
see it um it's probably overshadowed
just by the character and the reality
shows and stuff so um it's all good for
me but it was it was a [__] hell of a
deal I tell you that much I've seen you
like over the last few years kind of
just be tired of the character tired of
like yo guys I get it I get that this
happened I get that this happened I get
who I am I get what I've done but I also
got a a family I got people who you know
you know is that something that you've
cuz you know at the end of the day like
you said like people kind of when they
think of Ray J they think of certain
things in their head they think sex
tapes or they think of reality TV or a
crazy Breakfast Club call which was
legendary by the way um but you're like
I said thank you I mean some of the
things people say that I've done is like
man I seen this or you did that man that
[__] was dope I'm like uh thank you man
but I just think that like you're you're
so much more than that like do you feel
like now you're finally kind of getting
into a space where you're just kind of
at peace like hey people are going to
look at me how they're going to look at
me but I kind of know what's going on
you know what I'm saying yeah I mean you
know I always focused on the business of
everything it's always strategy behind
it I I am burnt out of being Ray J
though that's why I'm like I've been
telling the team like we got to take the
Jay off at some point this year and just
go with Ray Tron or Tron or Ray cuz uh
Ray J comes with a different kind of
like U stigma just the whole yeah it's a
whole another like life um and it's
lived [__] I'm lit forever I mean I you
you I'm sure you saw Vince Staples and
his his proclamations about you did you
see that you had to have seen that I
seen that I did I did some stuff with
Vince um after that like we did
something for his uh his uh uh I think
it was his YouTube channel but we did
some funny stuff together I I do think
he's right though because I think that
when it comes down to like what we're
seeing nowadays right like I think of uh
you know like the blueface cron show and
and that whole network like Zeus Network
I'm like yo this is all like this is
like a son of like what Ray J Like For
the Love of Ray J was like a show that
kind of like changed
entertainment like all all the Antics
aside yeah like you kind of kicked off a
whole wave of like just that we see now
yeah like reality is is is booming like
we've been in the game for like a decade
plus and now we starting another OT
platform it's called the Tronics Network
and um we doing a a compilation we like
we we doing a bunch of like content it's
similar to the stuff that we did um at
Zeus and at at Viacom where we at now
and we I got shows on every Network
three on Zeus I mean I don't I can't
count on other like linear networks but
the new network should like take off in
a crazy way too but um yeah we been we
just been working man everything been
going good you have any uh ownership
stake at Zeus No no no no not at all I
mean I have equity in every show that I
did there right um what shows were you
behind there well we we kicked I mean in
my opinion we kicked the whole network
off with uh the conversation mhm I think
that was the first super successful show
that uh Zeus had and then we we double
back with one more chance uh princess
myself and Jackie long and then we
double back after that and I connected
the dots with uh with the baddies so if
you look at the first season you see
executive produced Bas on the first
season um and and I think [__] I think
that's a [__] enough cuz that's all
the that's like I think with Joselyn
show ated in I mean the network that's
the power you know what I'm saying so
you know we just going to do it again um
and get in the game a different way have
most control over it I feel like it
needs a few um a few adjustments in the
reality as far as how loud it is it
needs some some positive uh some
positive endings and some like you know
lessons we can learn from all the
Ratchet [__] we might do there has to be
some kind of like lesson in love Yeah
character yeah so we want to provide
that T too and give everybody a chance
to eat and own all that [__] um on the
new network that we dropping so so
you're going to have your own network
coming it's on the way it's on the way
it's on the way right it's it's actually
in motion right now you tequila yes it's
in motion and some Calypso
Calypso
yes um I was going to needs to give us
an endorsement as well Amigos hey George
Clooney got paid yeah he did I always
like I feel like I was one of the last
people to realized that that is George
Clooney's autograph on the front of that
bottle yeah that's his and it's like oh
George Clooney's Rich yeah he did that
cuz I feel like if anybody won in the
pandemic it was
casamigos oh most definitely damn God
damn yeah you did you just do that he
did it just a little you remind me of
the Denzel movie Flight oh yeah I'm not
you're the drunk pilot no is there a cup
around do we have cups I think so you
got a cup TR thugy got to take a big sip
of this one yeah I think he's trying to
convince you to take a a shot of
diabetes to the head first there you
go and then a
little oh yeah did you drink the Chaser
first yeah hey let me get that let me
get one of these lemonades to chase with
let me get a swig hey we might as well
all drink right guys come on bro that's
what you want the blue of the paint what
do you guys think is better probably the
blue probably the blue blue 200 calories
of sugar
[__] my
diet cheers fellas we live in life man
hey so tell me about the uh competition
in the bay this weekend where you guys
are going to be having people riding we
in the bay Saturday we doing a bull
riding competition at Westwood um best
Rider you know most style kind of
sexiest best Vibe you know and then we
going to do in San Jose we doing a on
Sunday we're doing myth Day party but
you know so wait we in the bay Saturday
and Sunday oh [__]
okay okay that's what we doing so uh you
know we we about to like the bay and La
have always kind of been where we
started uh getting stuff popping so you
know we got to get our markets that have
always held us down right fully and
tuned with the song and then we going to
start a little Tik Tok campaign too you
know so uh you know most creative um
most creative video on Tik Tok you know
we start doing a comp 25,000 bucks and
this is for an electric bull riding
competition yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and there's more to come so what is
that he just got a no crib just a just a
creative house oh [__] creative facility
house we going do doing a couple in La
you feel me but pull up we doing some
crazy [__] over we just we just mobbing
man we just we just living life it's
like you know uh we believe in the
record you know it's a great hey it's a
it's a great record we just got right
now it's just about getting the uh the
eyes and the ears the kids to know that
that it's even out and then once they
know it's out it's like it's going to do
what it's supposed to do you know but
right now that's we here let people know
it's out let people know we got a a body
of music coming along with it you know
with the EP coming along with it and we
we just not playing we just want to make
good music and make good moments and you
know just leave our Legacy and just just
catch a VI is this our first interview
um um together propon the song yes it is
think so you guys never did one 13 years
ago no I'm talking about right now oh
for this one I even know if we did one
like human interaction together we never
did an interview 143 it's our first
interview when you I was going to ask
you Bobby when you're writing like when
you're a writer like you are right I
always wonder like what do you pick to
keep for yourself and what do you pick
to like give away man it's always been a
challenge like loyal the Chris Brown
song was supposed to be my song and then
uh nicknack wanted to give it to Chris
this new song for you as well and then
Ty was Ty was like me and Ty worked on a
loyal together Ty was like no bro I
worked on that one for you like that's
your song and then Nick was like no bro
we got to give it to Chris me and Nick
got in a big ass argument I'm like bro
you can't like like and then he finally
convinced me I was like fine Chris can
have it and then Ty and I convinced Ty
like he was like fine Chris can have it
and Chris went crazy with it bro like
and God I'm glad Chris took it you know
he made that song uh Ultra smash you
feel me yo you were shout out to Chris
Brown you were on a tour and like what
was the the name of the tour it was U YG
and Tai was it the young and hung over
tour young and hung over tour yeah no
what funny as I just watched that old
video last night I was clowning your
outfit you was clown on my outfit and
you also didn't know who Tai was and he
looked at crazy no idea who Ty was he
looked at you crazy I always show people
that I'm like yo yo this the guy on the
song you were like I don't know who you
are and he looked at you so no that was
When Ty only was on the two and boot at
hook and he had Allstar out yeah but but
like but it's just funny that those
moments I just I just rewatched that
maybe like a year ago cuz I was showing
my boy I was like yo I didn't an
interview and Ty was just standing there
I didn't know who the [__] he was yeah
what a great guy that's why Tai's like
my brother for life you feel me Ty
always been hella humble though greaty T
always would say back in the day when
people wouldn't know who he was he would
always be like it's okay I'mma have my
turn I'mma have my turn oh we're doing
science here boys he was just he was
always confident his talent like I'mma
have my turn it's all good I put out an
EP after 143 and I made a song with t
they didn't want to put that record on
the EP and I was like Ty bro I love you
bro but Universal won't let me put this
on the uh Universal won't let me put
this on the EP like they don't want like
they don't know who you are they won't
let me put this on he's like it's okay B
I'm have my turn and boy did he have his
turn and still having his turn you feel
me for sure Cheers Cheers Cheers Cheers
everybody getting their turn you feel me
I got now [__] the next [__] I got now
um so what is what is the plan with the
EP playing with the EP we going to
studio right after this you feel me I
got yeah you inspired I got y you
inspired Bobby let's go we working feel
let's go we got another hit coming out
called Birthday this what I told Bobby
like we got on top it's going to Bubble
as long as we keep working it let's make
it a a a a life longterm like goal to
make this a hit but if we drop another
Banger with it and another Banger with
it and give them these options all the
songs is going to blow up because now we
got a body of work that I think that
they not used to getting from us we'll
drop a song and it'll come out and do
well and then we like you know what I'm
saying
chill people do TV you know but it's
like no now we we focused man and it's
like a you know Ray said it shout out to
Y and tiger he was like yo bro we got to
keep hitting them like YG and tiger
hitting them they they hitting them
every two three weeks you feel so it's
like yo we got to hit them too we have
to where we can't survive you feel me we
we have to you can survive I'm talking
about I'm talking about musically we
can't survive it's like if it's
competitive and it's about like
marketing bread and it's about anything
like I'm ready to go like whatever we
need I'm ready to go I I really want to
drop like a bunch of songs together so
we just we like we we got a whole
[__] like concert we could do and
we've always had the quality but we
never had the quantity so now it's time
to merge them together so when we
dropping birthday we can put out I'm
thinking we put out our next songs in
probably the next two or three weeks
that's what the [__] I'm talking about
we drop birthday with on top I'm telling
you I'm I'm a marketer this birthday
record is
ski right I don't think people I I I
remembered so I I don't think people
understand how long you've been making
music because when I was probably 14
years old maybe 13 13 or 14 how was I 14
13 you were probably like 16 got it I
saw you at um you did like a Power 98.3
like Outdoor Show I forget who was all
on the [__] lineup but I remember you
were on the lineup and then I became an
intern like two or three years later no
before it was before this was let it go
before this was with like a Electra but
then yeah it was the Electra days but
then I was my first event I ever
interned ever in my life was a concert
in Phoenix and it was a kkfr show
and it was at Arizona Beach Club and the
lineup you were headlining damn it was
you then it was pretty Ricky and the
opener was Chris Brown D and it was at a
club that's unbelievable bro I've done
stuff like that my whole life it's like
like I've done like radio promo or jcole
open for me and stuff like it's just
like you never know you have your turn
you have your no I just think it's like
I just don't think people understand
like bro you're you've been around this
[__] for like ever yeah no I got the
templates for a lot of stuff and you
know know we took a lot of nose a lot of
times and a lot of like it ain't going
to happens and you know what I'm saying
a lot of doors was always shut um just
from a lot of different reasons and ways
that the the game go but it just you
know for us just we just always had fun
whether it was struggling to get the
records popping or having fun like on
top whatever it is like the hustle for
us good or bad has always just been fun
so on top video is fun too go watch the
on top music
yeah we got we we about to buy two
mechanical bulls this week we Ain we
ain't renting random I want them you
going to take you going to take back to
I did the pricing it's like 500 to rent
and it's like ,000 n you can get one for
like 7500 just Rand but I'm saying you
going to ship it back to LA I mean his
kid going his kids going to be bigger in
a couple years just you know something
hey guys I got a mechanical bull in the
garage whenever you guys the mechanical
bull in in in the Bay got to just come
rental but the one we got at the we want
to put at the house that we got now we
get one we get little personal
mechanical Advance the kids can ride it
in a couple years [__] sh throw you
offer a vibing it's like come on let's
go get on the bull man you feel me yeah
like it's about to be a Rayo and U and a
radio a r i like that R Drive yeah Rayo
dries heavy yeah That's Heavy but I was
thinking about the rodeo and I was
thinking about the radio but it just it
was a forc one but I tried hey we got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
partners at odd Soxs baby that's right
shout out to our family at odd Soxs man
look the most comfortable socks in the
entire world odd Soxs
official.com they just got the Coca-Cola
license they got the Scarface license
they got the WWE license they got
[__] Kool-Aid socks Chucky you know
what I'm saying Halloween's coming get
them [__] Chucky socks speaking of
Halloween what about the Ghostbuster
joints man W these are gas they even got
the Ghostbuster underwear what I'm
trying to tell you is whatever you're
into they got them at odd Sox odd Soxs
official.com they just locked in the
brand new uh saving uh uh what's it
called um well look they got
Transformers and Power Rangers that's
essentially what I'm trying oh Hasboro
the Hasboro license all right they got
all the socks draws all that [__] plus
they got the odd Sox Basics which are my
favorite just the normal guys I mean I
wear them every single day of my life
they're literally the most comfortable
socks and don't forget about the
underwear ladies and gentlemen the
underwear are there if you want to get
20% off at checkout go to oddsocks
official.com use that promo code bootleg
20% off at checkout odd Sox official.com
trust me all right you go get some of
these Odd Socks you put them on if they
ain't the most comfortable socks you
ever put on your [__] life you
know what I'm saying DM me I'm not gonna
reply but they because you're a liar you
know what I mean anyway also want to
give a big shout out to our family at
kinging pom baby that's right shout out
to King p man listen I've been smoking
these King pals since they've come on
board and I don't know what man look bro
these things right
here it's a tobacco free Leaf just
organic no no like uh no [__] you
know what I'm saying just
organic I mean this thing right here
this like it's it's natural what I like
about it you know what I'm saying now
this what I like about King Palms is I'm
went from smoking just straight papers
to strictly King Palms and I love it
because I like the way they burn and I
like the way they taste because what
they do have are these tpine flavor tips
yes they're infused on the tip tobacco
free you squeeze the
tip and it's a burst of flavor these are
the sugar punches shout out to Sugar
shano ali uh these are the dragon fruits
oh what do we got here what do we got
here we got grape they got all kinds of
flavors I mean literally watermelon they
got an energy drink flavor California
cream whatever it is and check this out
right now not only can you go and get
King palom at your favorite smoke shop
by your house maybe 711 pop in get you
some King pom whatever smoke shop is
near you has King poms liquor stores all
that but you can also go to the website
and get 50% off half off whatever you
want to order from King pom they got the
smoking accessories the astrays the
Grinders I mean the glass tips whatever
you're into King pom.com promo code
bootleg save 50% off at checkout shout
out to King pom man I'm about to smoke
up right now after this podcast all
right yo let's get back to the interview
you know uh I I always Ray do you ever
see what the like kind of like the wave
of only fans creation are you kind of
grateful that you didn't you weren't 20
when this popped off I no I was I'mma
keep it lit I was trying to get ready to
do it let's do some only fans version
for on top and we were thinking about it
then he was like no I don't want to do I
feel like if you were 21 years old right
now while only fans was popping be you'd
be our only fans no we would have did
the only fans on top video but Ray was
like I don't want to do that at the kids
we need to Market it for the kids that's
what I like he's a matured man you been
through that yeah I think you know what
I'm saying if you talking equity in
companies you know what I'm saying I
mean maybe only fans might owe us a
little Equity too you know what I'm
saying from just doors opening up from
crazy wild [__] happening and things
like evolving and sometimes you not
really evenly style you're not not even
happy about some of the [__] and um then
you just got to look at it and and uh
and just recreate the wheel every time
and don't look back you know what I
always wonder Ray I ever I always wonder
because you are Mr I hit it first but
you know who I think is truly he wrote
that song Mr I Hit It First is Scott
Storch have you and Scott Storch ever
hung out behind closed doors and just
shot the [__] about like you know your
guys's Hit List cuz that's got to be an
epic conversation hopefully a podcast
happens one day before both of you
demise nah not really I really never do
that like I mean you know know I mean
everything I really done in my career is
like a open book everybody know all the
bad times the good times everybody's
seen it you know what I'm saying so I'm
just like now just uh just trying to
stay uh humble and with gratitude to
everybody for even just you know what
I'm saying sticking with us through all
the things we've been through we we like
30 years in the game and still being
here is a blessing my voice Ain't Got
Deep yet so I'm still in the young crowd
a little bit MH you know what I'm saying
and it's just like we just got to keep
keep having fun and keep hustling uh a
lot of artists obviously you've done
kind of your version of this but like a
lot of artists these days there's
serious seven figure bags out there to
do a podcast yeah I feel like if you did
the Ray J podcast would go crazy I I
mean I do millions of dollars are just
ready for you for the taking if you did
I would love that like I I I got so much
[__] to get off my chest and so many
topics to touch on to go viral on like
I'm so chilled now because I know if I
just turn up just a little bit it's
going to go viral so I'm trying to calm
my virality down bu let me let me tell
let me tell you this let me get let me
give him another like Vince Staples
moment Legend like bro he'll just
casually tell me like yeah I'm like I'll
talk about Tupac Stories the all death
Ro like yeah Pac used to swoop me we
used to cruise up and down Sunset like
imagine how old were you when Tupac was
picking you up was he babysitting no no
Snoop was picking me up but Pac was
always at um was always at Can-Am you
know what I'm saying you remember Can-Am
I I was no of course not oh it was I
grew up in Phoenix I to pick me
up stories you a legend you feel me yeah
for sh Pac for sure man I mean [__]
that's [__] what's it like riding
like getting picked up by Snoop Dog as a
child I mean we're talking 90s Snoop
yeah this is it this is this this shit's
different well you know that's my cousin
no I'm saying but like what's that like
like Peak Snoop Dogg biggest rapper in
the world scooping you up you're riding
around with him well I was I I had to be
lowkey cuz Brandy was was super popping
at the is on TV she's one of the biggest
singers in the world you're her little
brother and it's clean cut on our side
then our cousin super lit so I had to
like hide you know what I'm saying but I
was having fun I was bad but um [__] by
the grace of God like we made it through
all of that cuz you know La is a
dangerous place and um you know [__] A
lot of people didn't make it through so
I'm I'm blessed and I'm just happy to be
here and I love everybody if I ever said
something crazy or we ever had an
alteration I love you I'm sorry I like
going to the grocery store by myself and
you know what I'm saying having a good
time with the family so if there's
anything out there that was irregular in
the past it's my fault even if it wasn't
I love you and peace be with you wow
turn the new Leaf man yeah man I like
that I feel like the new Leaf's been
turned for you for a while though though
yeah yeah I mean the shows that we do
don't reflect it a lot uh just just our
daytoday but I think I'mma just go ahead
and just like flip it around and just
really focus on like what the real
narrative is um and just take a backseat
to like doing the shows and just start
producing the shows you know what I'm
saying just not being on camera yeah I
mean yeah but you're so good on camera
you should start like a yoga Wellness
Retreat too me like show the show The
Grow I go to yoga three days a week what
you be doing in there hot yoga downward
dog pause huh
pause that's I mean that's what I should
be doing what's a downward dog pause
pause I mean that's yoga paes the
downward dog is way up there way that's
like
the that's a high L pause that's PA
pause of the what a week but it's bro no
it's not because have you done the down
dog in a room with is really good for
the Mind Body and Soul have you ever
done iasa I've never done I'm not a real
druggy kind of guy well first of all
yeah it's not drugs you did it I watch n
I've only done uh lots of mushrooms I
I'm not about to do the tow Venom and
then you got to put your whole back
together you have you smoked the toad
Venom i' had I had a shroom summer where
I was loving the chocolate shrooms no
DMT though no damn I don't do drugs bro
I don't do I
my my boy Aly David tried to get me to
come to Malibu and DMT with them but I
just like you should have did it N I
can't Mike Tyson does it all the time
like I don't want to do DMT and then
when I come when when I when I'm reborn
I'm like a Buddhist and I don't want to
do the music and Tech no more I'll be
mad I've had friends in Oakland who just
tried the wrong drug and they brains get
rewired and they just no before F like
they brains just get rewired and they
never the same so you got to be careful
with stuff I was just in Portland this
past weekend everyone's just doing drugs
on the street yeah no Portland you know
what else is like van it's legal though
in Portland all the drugs are legal so
you Vancouver you can shoot up heroin in
front of the cops and they're just like
you all right downtown San Francisco is
pretty bad you know San Francisco's
[__] up you know it's pretty bad but
it's like I just went to San Francisco
and we was trying to find the Golden
Gate Bridge we like I think it's way on
the other side I think we was adjacent
to it you hear I know how you see these
words I'm using adj to it
I'm like some of the most billionaire
some of the like highest rent and then
some of the most with extreme wealth is
Extreme poverty ever of course it's
crazy man it's Gotham City you feel me
but it's definitely Gotham City I love
the bay hey what up ba the princess from
the bay they love rain a b too you feel
me I'm Filipino now cuz princess
Filipino my kids Filipino Ray J Filipino
Filipino have you ever ate the ballute
the ballot yeah the the Filipino like
half eaten like half bird I eat chicken
adobo all the time I don't do the BL I
like the lumpia go has your lady ever
done it of course yeah has she done it
in front of you yeah yo shout out my
brother E40 he does open he's opening up
alumia he's got theia company yeah it's
open up an alumia rest Lumia is like the
Filipino kind of like egg roll kind of
the small word oh Lumia is fire you had
but I didn't know like we talking about
blut and all this
stuff just opening up a rest St like it
threw me off you know what I'm saying
crazy I you can hear you can hear the
little bones crack I could say this
entrepreneurial wise E4 and and Ray got
a lot of parallels yeah you guys really
do honestly doing different like e he's
got like 38 businesses alol company let
me tell you something E40 is a great guy
man I love him he's a great guy it's
hust it's California hustle West Coast
yo you got to launch a podcast and your
first episode should be with Scott stor
E40 for different reasons I mean the
thing about it is like I want to l a
podcast like I don't know I do like my
own podcast at home for fun and look at
it and laugh with guests bro you [__]
it's it's a million dollars easy for you
D all my podcasts I did at home just for
fun you got to really like take it
serious dude I've been taking it
seriously I got like I got like 50
episodes that that's just throw ways I'm
never going to use them but that's how
much I be having fun crib set up a
podcast room and but you got to do one
like at least three four times a week no
you got to drop once a week if they if I
listen
if I get the proper bag me and my team
will produce 25 shows a week that's too
much no it's not no Ray let me tell you
what it is store I'm store this is what
you do how many well you already got a
YouTube
channel I got a YouTube channel but I
never promoted it now it's Ray J TV I
got like 8,000 subscribers no but where
the [__] are your songs
at on Vivo you feel which one where they
at rayj Vivo okay Vivo okay well listen
Ray Ray J Vivo I thought they was on
Spotify I'm telling you if you just La
first of all you did we get my code yet
you don't need The Upfront bag yo
Spotify Spotify do it for 6 months on
your own and then you'll be able to get
a stupid back you just got to tell me
the number so we'll know how to scale it
on our own and then build it you know
what I'm saying you have the YouTube
Revenue you be able to get your own
sponsorship money but [__] all that once
oh [__] why is he here yo right no ke
let me ask you a question so keev Jesus
[__] Christ for on top you like the
song what's our next move what's our
next play for what for your guys' music
yeah for for for our for our song you
tell me I want pi your prank I think you
guys are already doing the right [__] to
drum up Buzz I think like I saw like you
guys are on TMZ I think you know the Tik
Tok shit's always important shout out to
TMZ I would say whatever you guys do
don't spend money in the wrong places
cuz I see artists nowadays you going to
bring us when are you going to bring us
to AR what what are the wrong places you
know I see [__] rappers these days
they'll be like yo um I hired this
person and they got me on complex well
you br us to Arizona K we'll work on
that but I'm saying like for any up andc
coming artist if someone [__] tries
to sell you on getting you on like
lyricallemonade.com or complex.com
keep your [__] money cuz you might as
well just set it on fire in the middle
of what about what about what about what
about what about wmart what about
Walmart walmart.com I didn't ask you
Walmart anybody can get on Walmart.com
you need eCommerce [__] I just want
you I'm just want you to teach them cuz
if they say well forget this time put
you on Walmart balloon with our faces on
it that should be I mean listen I mean I
want to know some of your do you think
you're going to get the ROI on the on
the on the water on the balloon in the
air absolutely not but it could be
organically it'll go viral for a day but
will that translate to streams prob
let's talk let's talk about conversion
marketing after this and talk about what
we got at end of
anything you guys do should try to be
how do we convert that into listeners a
bag for Kev before we leave I don't need
a bag but I want you to have one does
shut the [__] up I want you to have one
you fat [__] who's got this guy's got
[__] Super Trooper shades
on anyway Big B um so so look he's my
best friend and my manager and it com
you didn't really give me you told me to
do not you didn't give 58 years old he
about so so Bobby Bobby brackens is is
really wants the the good advice from
you on what to do I think I think number
one is consistency especially for you
let's say take RJ out of the picture
you're very inconsistent with your music
yeah yeah no he's right super
inconsistent Kev is right cuz I feel
like maybe 2017 I remember you had the
single with G or was that 2018 one was
in day they went crazy but the thing is
is like you'll put some [__] out and
then you'll go away so it's like bro you
can't
expect now we about to go to the studio
to go ahead and get give it to him like
stay with you because the span of all
these fans is this big so they're going
to forget about you there you go so I
want the good advice I don't want the do
I'm giving you I'm giving you good
advice consistency cuz you can look at
some of your your peers just from your
area right who's been super consistent
Larry June uh burner Mai from Sacramento
like Mazi just nonstop it's like he's
just feeding his fans so my thing with
you is like Bobby you are a talented
artist you do have a fan base you have
listenership on Spotify feed them
consistently and don't and if something
does work one not every song needs a
budget not every song needs a radio
campaign there we go now you giving
there are context records that you could
drop just to feed your fan base and
guess what if you drop and you're like
oh [__] this [__] organically is doing
its own thing the fans will tell you we
need to put a little bit of gasoline on
this that's what the and that's what the
body of work so they'll be like yo we
love this on top is big but this [__] we
going crazy over we scale this one then
on Top com back and and then the other
thing is like I tell you this kid can I
tell you something real quick like my
thing R knows too like just being around
me I never I never cared about being the
most famous person I just love making
music if I got to if I got to put it no
you're obviously a successful artist but
you can't love it and keep it to
yourself the world need to experience it
with ex exactly if I got to if I'm
giving it to other people I'm fine with
that but it's like if I'm sitting on a
million records on my email that I know
somebody needs to cut what got to start
dropping a lot of artists Amigos got me
sweating like a [__] a lot of
artists will outthink themselves shirt
sweating and [__] are we getting naked
boys zipping my [__] up yeah I do that
any well he's getting naked yeah anymore
of course you know do you still get a
bag off of that like any sort of
residual check man I've really just been
focused on you know the tech and you
know but does a check come in still well
what happened was you know after I start
going to the gym I just started to lose
focus on like everything on that kind of
side of things and like life so I've
been just kind of forgetting
about my my uh my son's best friend's
cousin's mom is married to the guy who
owns Vivid so yeah yeah so and like he's
like best friends with Chris Paul's son
and [__] so my son was greaty my son was
just over at his house for a birthday
party and he was like I was at the house
that porn built I was like yes you were
yeah Steve's a good guy so you have you
still have you have a relationship with
Steve hi Steve not really I mean I love
Steve but I in good bus you know when
you become a dad and just stay just
change it around and grow you you rarely
reach out to anybody you just so like
locked down locked up you you got kids
too I have two kids is that a Sublime
tattoo yeah [__] that's like my second
favorite band ever I didn't know you was
tatted up like that yeah yo what age
were you when you got these tattoos some
of these look like they're jail house oh
you know up different ages 18
1921 some are jailhouse some are very
professional this is like hipster no
there's some that look really good and
then like the sublime tattoo I'm a
Sublime fan I know what it is but like I
got that a minute ago do I got another
t-shirt do you want a shirt I mean I'm
wet pause pause pause I got it's under
these lights but it's all gring oh yeah
you're sitting right under the light
you're the problem is is that that's the
only thing that KAS Amigos need to take
away from their drink is that it creates
sweat and they if they can take the
sweat the sweat ingredient out where you
can drink and don't sweat then casamigos
will be popping but I swear I don't swe
make it you make that liquor with where
you don't
perspire perspiration to kill it is also
kind of hot here I'm just not in the
liquor business we just moved into the
space and we're still trying to get the
AC together guys yeah no doubt it's it's
just I'm happy be bro holler at 40 bro I
even know some vendors up in NAA Valley
no no I don't want to get in liquor
business question um Ray you in my
opinion Dr you're a great example of
somebody who has made a Rel a
relationship work through the public eye
in the in the highest like I mean like
literally like I can only imagine like
the Peaks and valleys some of them we
know about when it comes to your
relationship but like what would be your
advice to just like making marriage work
even through the tough the tough [__]
cuz I just got married like four years
ago so well I mean you know you got kids
and you love your wife and you go
through the ups and downs and a lot of
people say you know you got to be happy
first right you protect your happiness
and that's that's fine
but I just look at it differently it's
like if my kids are super happy and my
wife is super happy that makes me happy
because if I'm not with them I'm sad
happy wife happy life but even just when
I wasn't with them and I and you know
you starting to go through these
different things about the time you
going to spend with the kids and the
days you get them and all of these
things start to make you feel like
depressed and sad and it's like to try
to be happy when you know your happiness
lies within your family and then it's
like if you a man of your word like if
you really a man of your word and you
made this
vow right like you like you ran it you
said I like I got you like till it's
over and then you go back on it how you
going to say that like you you really
your word is all that matters you know
what I'm saying so I just started
looking at it from a different way and
all the bad and the good it all weighs
in to the love and the family so I'm
like I'm riding to the wheels fall off
kids are adorable too like both of them
are adorable and Melody like I don't
know if you seen one wish Melody been a
turn a name Ray this guy sweating like a
hor in church you if you seen the one
I'm swe I'm sweating like a prostitute
in the front row at church Ray got a ray
got a song called Melody that TI Alan
loves but if you watch the one which
video the he girlly texting his Melody
that's his daughter's name he got a real
connection with the with with Melody
Shir extra shirt gang bath towels face
towels hand tows I'm overprepared this
guy's
persa you got the heat on the for no no
no it's cuz you're standing underneath
that light can we give a can we give a
shout out to how things come back into
fruition uh um um One Wish just keeps
going reviral like every five years it
just keeps going reviral you feel me
reviral reviral you feel me that's when
you over viral it's like things will go
viral for a day you feel me what up guys
we got to stop the interview to tell you
about our good Folks at my bookie NFL
season is upon us and let me tell you
something my bookie uh this new season
is going to be crazy because right now
at my bookie you could do the early cash
out that's right if you're betting maybe
you got a parlay going the first two
legs here parlay hit you want to cash
out early guess what you can now do that
at my bookie all right or you can let it
ride you know maybe flip it into a
bigger parlay it's up to you and NFL
season is finally here though all right
so look what I need y'all to do is H go
to
mybookie.ag right now sign up all right
with that promo code bootleg and this
season we are not playing there is a no
strings attached cash bonus that's right
it lets you deposit and withdraw quick
all right on a deposit of $50 or more
you can receive up to $200 in cash
instantly to your mybookie account no
strings attached this is crazy by the
way this is like revolutionary if we
will I mean come on what are we doing go
to mybookie.ag sign up with that promo
code bootleg right now and on a deposit
of $50 or more you can receive up to
$200 in cash instantly in your mybookie
account no strings attached let's get
some Futures going who you think's going
to win the Super Bowl who do you think's
going to win week one let's get that
week one action already rolling in all
right I cannot wait my favorite part of
the year to gamble is NFL season and now
is the time and if you're not into
football they also got the full service
casino slots all the table games card
games whatever you're into mybookie.ag
go make your first deposit with that
promo code bootle when you sign up for a
new account and get free cash all right
also I want to give a shout out to our
family and my bookie wait I already
shout it out my bookie I want to shout
out to uh blue Chu man shout out to Blue
Chu look blue Chu if you did not know
fellas if you're out there dealing with
some sort of erectile dysfunction your
dick game could be a little bit more raw
you know what I'm saying sound like a uh
a goddamn what was a guy his name who
did
panda panda panda that was a designer ad
lip anyway listen um if you uh are
dealing with stress at work maybe your
dick is not working the way you'd like
it to or you could just little little
little more else pep in your step go to
blu.com right now use the promo code
bootleg when you uh go there and they're
going to give you your first month for
free blu.com promo code bootleg now what
is blue does it work of course it works
all right what is it it's the same
active ingredient as Viagra and Calis
but it's in a chewable form and you
don't have to go to the doctors for it
that's the best part you just go online
you handle your business you get the
first month for free when you sign up
with that promo code bootleg all right
um and listen it goes straight to your
door it's in a chewable form very Reet
no awkward conversations about your dick
with strangers no you just go on the
website handle your business there all
right blu.com promo code bootleg trust
me it's summer well end of summer to be
honest Summer's about to be [__] over
with all right so you know you you
listen cuffing season's on the way
before you know it you're going to close
your eyes boom cuffing season and you're
going to want to make sure your dick is
in the uh you know best possible
position to impress so go to blu.com use
that promo code bootleg and get your
first month for free let's get back to
the interviews um Bobby outside of you
and ra I ask you a question real quick
you keep that on your mom how awkward
was it when homie walked out on you it
was actually funny so did you feel super
uncomfortable I mean he was like an hour
and a half
late he may or
may I'm not even gonna get into me and
Ray yes she
wasn't a little bit late he R was early
4 minutes not expecting punctuality from
both so 12:45 I mean because being on
time in my business is is is all there
is late [__] up a whole deal for me and
so when he when he got here he was he
didn't want to be here like what I don't
what I what I don't get is if you a
artist and you want to share your music
and you want more eyes and ears on it
why go do an interview with Attitude
exactly like why even come and that and
the thing is is like I don't get that as
an artist just like if you don't want to
be here then cancel I agree and that was
kind of where and then the thing is is
his team had kind of and I'm going be
real with you bro no disrespect to him I
like his music Kev I'm going to be real
with we got a horse bath going on over
here I'm be I'm going to be real with
you I'm going to be real with you hey
Bob you ever wash your dick in the sink
after a long night I don't think
so um little sink dick wash before you
go home I'm going to be real with you
can I be real with you K yeah you
weren't being rude to no like something
like when we were in Vegas for fun you
were making fun of my pants like I was
also you know what that was a different
me I was very like now you making fun of
tattoos but it's all no no no so let me
say this so the The estg Thing One his
team had kind of prepared me for like
that he wanted to talk about different
[__] they said he he's a Joe Rogan fan
and he like well they they just told you
they he want to talk about football so
they didn't say that oh so it wasn't
even football I found out later he has
beef with some rapper from Louisville
and in the v so I guess there's a dis on
I like I love his music he I like I'm
just saying that that that whole moment
I already know what that whole moment
was did you see his viral moment what
happened just walked out he just stood
up walked out cuz he's I don't know dude
Fu who walked out estg estg for he
signed a y Gotti okay he dope he hard
okay but yeah he just stood up and
walked out damn man I was like
world you made mad I didn't know what I
bro he was mad already that's all I'm
telling Kev is he didn't it wasn't I
didn't do I didn't say nothing crazy it
wasn't like you were like prying at him
there's a reason why he he was mad he
asked me what YouTube video I saw that
picture on because I was informed by his
team later on that there was a there's a
disc record where the artist who's
dissing him uses the picture of him at
the NFL combine in the video which I
didn't know but he thought I was asking
him about that pict picture cuz I had
watched that this video yeah it was some
it was some weird but look but look I
got 25,000 for the best mechanical bull
rider in the bay and then we going to
follow up in Los Angeles California so
you're going to do 25k in each city um I
might it just depends on how the turnout
is like if the turnout is turning out
and the record is starting to turn up
can men uh participate or no right right
yeah right
right franisco in San Francisco I said
no because uh um you know our our girl
you know men want money too men want
money but I'm saying I wouldn't be able
to judge the the like most sexy man no
but I thought it's whoever is it whoever
judge the most sexiest man for sure
pause you know what I'm saying for sure
I mean yeah that's super pause yeah
super pause but but but you got to
understand for me you know an ugly
man so at the new Tronics Brian Samson
ugly so so I got the Tronics Network
right the Tronics Network we have a
whole full facility upstairs is the gcy
oh right and so the gcy really focuses
on
the the highest quality of talent for
the lgbtq plus right they love rap
there's rency I don't know there's the
G I don't know you know what goes v
every um every week you know every every
what's the week called um Pride week
every Pride week um what goes viral is
shout out to all my gay [__] oh yeah
that's when I said well well here's why
because I have another I have another
you know C3 Foundation it's called Ray
and so you know instead of it being gay
pride it's it's Ray Pride because we
supporting many gays got support
everybody so you got R A and then you
got me like this why and then you got
Pride so yeah I got friends trans
friends I got all the friends we support
everybody have you ever performed at a
pride event I heard they get active are
they abely I haven't yet well well well
the one that I performed at the big one
where it was like a thousand people they
really was like loving princess so when
I came out I was was like I don't know
they were they they wasn't going crazy
but when Princess walked out it was
crazy and then they was she known to be
oh n n they just love princess they was
cool with me they was like what's up Ray
J I was doing sex I was doing sexy I
thought it was when I walked out it was
going to be
pandemonium and when I walked out it was
cool and then they like whistle they
went and then like 15 dudes came out
with socks on their dick and they just
started to go crazy and then it was like
it happened did you have a sock on your
dick no I didn't have a sock on mine
yeah yeah no I had mine just but anyways
if if Ray wants men to be able in my
underwear if Ray wants men to be able to
be a part of the challenge I'm fine with
that I'm just saying I personally
wouldn't be able to know what a sexy
well here's why we bring the gcy in you
got to bring the gcy in in be to be like
going
czy man I would be like so it's not the
contest isn't who can stay on The Bard
the longest no it's just who got the
most drip got the most to VI I thought
it was who could stay on the bll the
longest no hell no got you got the best
you got you got good you got a good drip
can you can you do a trick can you can
you do a trick you got stage you got
stage performance you got personality
you got Charisma well we just giving 25k
to the best Rider right and then you got
best
theer best Rider stays on the long well
there's other layers and [__] to it too
so we giving other money out to like
best dress best attitude what but the
best bull riding performance gets to to
25 are you going to ride that bull um
well pause but um probably not that one
um because my back and my leg been hurt
that should have [__] you up I did
that [__] in Austin and I got [__]
yeah that's what I'm saying I'm having a
little bit of top tea or crop
top who's the young lady on the cover
she on the cover Spotify Apple music
what is her name cuz people be asking me
K Kira yeah she is she have a last name
or just Kira does she have an only no I
just I'm not sure we make sure we can
support her hustle you know no so when
they say who's that girl I just say Kira
um yeah let's figure out we'll figure it
out later yeah but I just I didn't have
the right proper name for it I can't
figure out I'm kind of dyslexic a little
bit no you good don't worry about it I
got Bobby brackens from here so yeah so
we got the new on top record we super
lit in here y'all our plan was not to go
viral today it wasn't it was to come in
here and promote with our our brother
Kev like there's some kind of viral
moments that I smelled in this thing
that happened I definitely feel it but
that wasn't our goal if it does top yes
Bobby is creating viral energy I would
like to point out right Bobby has viral
energy going on and I respect you
turning the the leaf on your life and I
don't want to add to any of your
thank here here's the thing I you know
whatever is in front of me whether it's
a question or a theme or a topic you
know for me to respond the way I respond
is what matters yes you know that's what
what matters I don't think it's the the
questions or the topics I think it's
just how I respond is really what what
people are paying attention this is the
main things let's just talk about the
bullet points is um on top is out right
now Spotify Apple music the video out
Vivo we got to got listen we got a
positive video and we got a dirty video
yo we got we got a we got a we got a
more dirty video it's more provocative
more a little more booty no but we about
to do no no no we about to do one like
that though I'm directing it but Bobby
Bracken is going to be the star you
going be [__] in it I told Ray I want
to do that from the
[Music]
GetGo but anyways let me talk about the
bullet points on top video is out right
now song video and then also we got a
San Jose myth we got our mechanical bull
competition 25 bands to the most dripped
up swagged out Rider who goes on on
there and goes the dumbest male or
female or trans well or trans or or or
pans or or pans pansexual and then the
other thing
is or intersexual the other thing the
other thing is LGBT Plus or lesbian yeah
yeah straight I got my my club called
the 915 Club 915 [__] shout out to
Central C for his line for whatever but
I don't even care if you a lesbian was
the first l i don't a lesbian 915 Club
[__] 915 uh the do how can I be hob my
[__] get exactly but but I don't even
care if she's a lesbian was the first
line like that I'm I'm not I'm that M
but anyways 9:15 Club what's that uh you
see can I talk about can I talk about
the one more bullet point quick one more
bullet point uh shout out to the
everybody gay straight TR 9:15 was that
on the bullet points when you came in
you know shout out to everybody cuz I I
said only women for the Riders but shout
out to pan shout out to the gcy 9:15
Club on mine I said only women for the
Riders but Ray Ray's Ray Ray wants
everyone so everyone I want everybody
because I love everybody I got a lot of
friends in every every category okay
every category every shape and size I
got a friend whether it's in the big
category or the little category okay
whether it's big people or little
peopley people or SK with big girls you
feel me all I used to do was mess with
got married she was probably like 2 215
man when I was 14 see now I'm about to
go viral I'm not going to do it no come
on what what happened when you were 14
not going to do it y I'm going to keep
it real I'm going to say something out
of pocket but I'mma keep it real it's
not your your texts are so zoomed in do
you have bad do you have bad eyesight
horrible prescription Kev son at my Kev
you're not listening to me Kev can I
speak with you can I speak with you or
not oh my God you're blind Kev may I
speak with you or not yes can we can we
show people how zoomed in this is right
can I ask you a question bro he's not
going to answer it but R Ray's been
popping a long time I'm sure when he was
14 15 16 a lot of older women taken
advantage of him you poached what's the
heaviest Queen you've poached no I'm
saying were you getting taken advantage
of as a teenager by older women well
well um well baby if you listening this
when I was younger so you can't you know
what I'm saying you can't count this but
N I used to get bathed because I was a
dirty kid right so my older my older
home girls used to put me in the tub and
bathe me because every time I took a
shower long long long time ago I used to
dry off and the tow still be dirty oh
wow so so so they they they said get
back in the tub and they going to wash
me down because ain't no way that towel
still that that that that that dirty and
that's the life of when you poping when
you 15 okay so when me when you were
getting bathed did they give you a
little hand
well it was a it was a well she they was
you know what I'm saying they was with
me anyway that was my older thing but
they would scrub me like I was like like
just jofy jofer so would you like get
scrubbed and jerked in the in the tub um
well it was a long time ago so I I
wasn't ready to get into details but all
I'm saying is I'm sure he was getting
taken advantage of as other other youth
well my babysitter took advantage of me
when I was young how old was
she she was young it's hard to think
about it I get I get hard thinking about
it you get hard thinking about it I mean
it's hard to think
about no but anyways no detail okay look
the new song on top is Out featuring
pilo produced by Nick Knack produced by
nicknack featuring pilo every city the
Bay Area wild949 K we need y'all love
hey call Big Von don't tell them tell
like box who no my box cev my bad ble
cev my bad
[__] you got going on over here no more
Kev my bad bro my B Kev here's what
happened here's what happens this is
what
happened and he's dlex Y no no time out
time out time out boev do you kind of
like the song yeah it's a good record
are you going to play the record for
radio station yes cuz we we made another
hit for the radio station was Heavy n
don't play us bro I want heavy rotation
don't do that y we want heavy rotation
whatever he just did we won we won we
won 90 spin a week yo yo yo yo right yo
back me up on this yo radio stations
give us 90 spins a week um Tik Tock do
the best Tik Tock content this guy's
just not stopping is he no Ray listen to
back me up back me up you not are you
backing me up oh yeah no I am Tik Tok
content we want the best Tik Tok cont
the best Tik Tok content out there we
want the best bull riders we want you to
get on your whatever you got your bench
or your floor and want you to play the
song on top download it and get to it if
you get to it by October 1st I'm giving
$100 to $200 a day to the best most
creative performer every day just
because I need your help could be funny
a good dancing good dancing it could be
funny I tried not to go viral today it
could be funny it could be I told you I
didn't want to go viral today all right
we're ending the interview I did
something was viral about this [__]
we'll see
s new song everyone go support the
record stream out my brother listen um
we know we going we going have some
conversations no no I'm about technology
and other opportunities give me some
this ain't got nothing to do with all
right we're head the interview today
you're not hating on my pants today
normal jeans [__] we got you look like
you're about to [__] plow a goddamn
field and those like they a goddamn John
Deere driver bro well these are good
pants those look like like Nashville
country bar pants all right so yeah so
thank you guys for for having us and um
you know I want to thank everybody out
there for supporting us Kev thank you
for let's no no we got to leave on we
already left we already left Bobby we
already left cut the camera it's
over yo thank you for supporting us hi
Mom apprciate who he keep talking to hi
Mom hope I made you proud hey what up
man uh you just watched another episode
of the blle C podcast brought to you by
Harden baby shout out to the family at
harden don't forget make sure if you're
in Las Vegas you get into that taxi as
soon as you land you get into that Uber
say take me to harden all right they
going to take get you taken care of the
most craziest Premium Selection of
cannabis you'll ever find Under One Roof
it's a vibe in there the butt tenders
they going to take care of you man
listen tell them I sent you they're
going to get you right shout out to the
family at harden in Las Vegas the number
one dispensary in the world all right
and we are so proud to be partners with
them so shout out to harden go follow
him online Harden _ Las Vegas and check
out their website Hardin Las vegas.com
get you some swag you know you can't buy
this but you know yeah shout out to
harden